how do we work out the total distance
traveled okay how do I got this now our
first approach was a fairly sort of
pedestrian approach we just looked at we
we had already looked out where this
stationary point was okay so all we need
to do was work out the upward journey
the downward journey and you add them
together you get this nobody twenty
three point nine six when you put those
pieces together okay that do we have
reason to trust that answer does that
does it see reasonable yes it doesn't
sit there is there any other part of the
journey that we've missed no it's a very
simple journey right so therefore you
should have a lot of trust
it is answer you don't have an answer
and I come over nice and I say to you
how confident are you that that's the
answer should be very confident that
that's the answer okay you've already
done all of this work to establish that
the numbers are right it is twelve point
four eight sure enough and that's what
you get
and then I posed the question how else
could you do this it's how you said to
me you can integrate with respect to
time that'll give you total change
accumulated change that's what
integrations about right if I work out
from here to here from naught 2 and we
worked out that that was about three
point one three okay we should get some
something that should be equivalent so
you working out this an integral from
naught to three point one three and most
of you integrated X with respect to time
you're interested in how this place was
changing over time what you got was this
number thank you sorry I'm healthy
remember it was three five three six
twenty six point five something right
and you like it's in the right ballpark
so it passes the the the common-sense
test right but but it's we establish
before and we just live at the point
that we should have a lot of chance for
this answer so what is this where is
this now I'm just gonna let that matter
answer that question rather settle in
your head for the new I'll let me tell
you what the problem was there are two
problems okay
firstly if you want to know how
displacement changes over time you did
not integrate displacement you integrate
velocity let me say that again if you
want to know how displacement changes
over time you need to evaluate
displacement over time not the integral
of displacement over time so really what
you should have worked out is not to
3.13
of velocity with respect to okay that's
what you should really be working out
okay now here's the theme that we know
what the integral of velocity will be
it'll be this equation right - you're
not stick because it's gonna add it
subtract but I know what the values are
at these points right when I do this
some equation here okay
remember I'm something I'm something in
time this is X as a function of time
okay what is what's the displacement at
three point one three seconds I'm at the
ground right it's zero here's my upper
bound right what's Y displacement at
time zero it's our one meter about the
ground right so there's my lower bound
so the answer I get off this integral is
negative one but what does it mean
what is it signifying it signifies total
displacement from time zero to type
three point one three can you see what
that is have a look where did I stop I
started here where did I end I ended
here the total displacement what meter
down with because that's what the board
did okay so we already worked out the
first problem that what you need to
integrate was not X its its velocity
with respect to time so there's your
first problem your second problem though
is that doesn't end up helping you
working out the turbulence is traveling
right of course it doesn't help you
because it's not a distance equation
it's a displacement equation it only
tells you how far you away you are not
how far you've traveled right doesn't
take into account you've got up or down
or whatever right
if you wanted to do some kind of
integration I guess what you would do is
you would integrate from north to the
stationary point that'll give you a
distance then you double it and then you
had one for that final leg of the
journey but that's kind of awkward being
that you already know what that number
is and you worked it up by much simpler
methods than integrations okay
so or I should say you've already done
the integration to get to this equation
so you might as well not do it again
just use that fact okay so in summary if
you're working on the term this is
travel
you should always appeal back to this
kind of argument I went this way and
then I went that way and I add them up
that's the simplest way to do it it's
the most foolproof right if you resort
to integration a definite integral right
you you really run the risk of confusing
yourself quite dramatically right
especially if you've already worked out
all the numbers you require okay so be
very cautious with these questions
simple things
understand the difference between
displacement and distance